also müssen einfach ohne begnade sehr
für dieses Ziel weil sonst funktioniert
das leider beim Ruder nicht weil es ist
bei uns so eng und so schwierig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
das ist österreichischen Bundesheers
heute zu Gast oder koperal Julian
Schöbel herzlich willkommen hallo Andi
servus du hattest deine größten Erfolg
vergangenen Sommer bei der
Europameisterschaft in München oder im 5
Platz belegt hast im einer erzähl mal
wie diese Europameisterschaft für dich
abgelaufen ist die Europameisterschaft
weil nicht richtig cool also es war ja
ähm es war eine nur für Rudern die
Europameisterschaft sondern insgesamt
für mehrere Sportarten gleichzeitig und
bei mir war das eigentlich recht spontan
dass sie also das war meine Entscheidung
das haben die vaterlichen getroffen dass
ihm einer Staaten wird wenn man ein
Partner leider vor krank war und nicht
das Trainingspensum gehabt hat bzw
trainieren haben können miteinander und
deswegen haben wir dann kurzfristige
entschieden dass im einer Stadt und ab
dem Vorlauf habe ich schon gemerkt okay
es funktioniert ich bin nicht so
schlecht im einer ich habe das danach
sehr genossen weil es einfach so eine
coole Veranstaltung weiß was so ein
riesen Event und das ganze Team war ein
bisschen hat man wir haben alle
miteinander zusammenkäufer so wie es
funktioniert und das war dann echt schön
also für mich war das echt da wirklich
schönes und cooles erwähnt Event an
diesem Jahr erinnern wird ist das für
dich auch ein Indiz dass das jetzt
öfter in einer mehr Stadt für dich geben
sollte also ich war richtig gerne nach
einer also dadurch dass sie diese gibt
dass sie da recht kurz Gefühl dafür habe
aber für mich ist immer das Ziel die
Olympischen Spiele und das gibt's halt
nur im Doppel zwei und deswegen wir ja
im Doppel zwei fahren und ich bin
hoffentlich hoffentlich sagen meine
Kollegen dass ihr guter team player bin
also ich habe sehr gerne im Team das
heißt im Endeffekt machst du gerne
beides aber Abwechslung mal zu wissen du
bist jetzt komplett allein für Dich für
die Leistungen für das Endergebnis
verantwortlich normalerweise sitzt ja
mit dem anderen Boot das ist die
Verantwortung danach aufgeteilt wie war
das so der Unterschied im Rudern selbst
ein bisschen Doppel zwei muss man
natürlich auch seine 100% geben und ihr
verlasst natürlich sie auf den anderen
das serbisch ist am einer und
dadurch
mit den ganzen Physios und mit der
ganzen vaterlichen deswegen habe ich nie
das Gefühl dass er wenn in einer bin
weil auf der Seitenlinie hat man genug
Trainer die also die sind immer live
dabei im Rennen aber natürlich muss sie
danach Rudern aber im Doppel zweier ist
er angenehmer wenn man hinter sich hin
oder vor sich hinhaut und miteinander
Nachfolger zieht das ist genauso schön
also das ist fast sogar noch schöner
aber es bringt halt noch eine
zusätzliche Ebenen Komplexität mit
Abstimmung mit äh man muss auch zusammen
funktionieren das ist ja nicht immer so
gegeben oder ja also das schon also es
ist natürlich schwieriger arbeitet einen
anderen Sachen ja dass sie das perfekt
zusammenpasst und damit man sehr perfekt
zusammen stimmt von ihm Training bis hin
zum Weg kommt bis zur Vorbereitung
direkt vorm Rennen aber wenn das gut
klappt dann steht ja am guten Wettkampf
nichts mehr im Wege also es ist recht
bisschen was anders es ist schon was
anders aber es ist ja was schönes das
hat zwar gesagt immer einer kann es
nicht zu den Olympischen Spielen gehen
die brustklasse ist nämlich nicht
olympisch weil es das leichtgewichtsboot
ist habe ich das richtig verstanden
welche welche einer werden olympisch ja
rödern ist in der Hinsicht mit dem
Bootsklassen ehrlich recht einfach ist
es eigentlich ohne schweren Bus
Klassenzimmer olympisch außer bei den
leichten bei den leichten ist anders als
nur der Doppel zwei olympische also nur
wenn man zu zweit im Boot sitzt und zwei
Bruder jeweils in der Hand hat das ist
olympisch und im einer der einen
Leichtgewicht eines nicht beste
besetzt deswegen meiner Meinung noch
weil dadurch ist der leichte Doppel zwei
ist halt also wenn man die stärksten der
Welt sitzen immer im leichten Doppel
zwei oder der dritte der Ersatz macht
das
mindestens genauso stark aber vielleicht
ein bisschen schwächer und das macht den
einer am recht spannender gibt es da
Ambitionen dass das auch olympisch wird
oder ist das kategorisch dass dieser
brustklasse neolympisch sein wird also
ich bin leider nicht dafür verwickelt in
den ganzen Prozess also was olympisch
scheiße sind und was nicht aber es wird
sicher nicht beschwert überlegen ob das
generell die Gewichtsklassen beim Rudern
abschaffen also das ist das so ziemlich
sicher noch Paris dass das gar nicht
mehr geben soll Leichtgewicht und
Schwergewicht sondern nur noch
Schwergewicht was was bedeutet
eigentlich so oder was kann ich darunter
vorstellen wenn man überhaupt keine
Ahnung hat vom Bruder
Durchschnitt muss 70 Kilo im Ruderboot
sein beim
teamsports Bote und also man kann 72 5
haben das ist das Maximalgewicht was er
oder haben darf beim Leichtgewicht und
der andere darf dafür 67,5 haben dann
hat man genau den Schnitt von 70 Kilo
und alles was drüber ist ist einfach
Schwergewicht man kann aber aus
Leichtgewicht da die Schwergewichte
starten werde das ist offene Klasse
sozusagen hat man dann aber einen
Nachteil weil man weniger Wasser hat
oder weniger also wo liegt der Nachteil
gegenüber Schwergewicht zu dann erst
recht dagegen wenn zum Beispiel da liegt
der Nachteil wenn der Gegenwind und es
gibt mehr um Kraft da ist natürlich der
Schwergewicht oder ein bisschen besser
natürlich ist es auch immer schneller
werde ich dann kräftiger sie sind zwar
nicht unbedingt ausdauernde die gleiche
Ausdauer und ihre Leichtgewichte aber es
ist einfach kräftiger und das macht
glaube ich ja schneller aber nicht um da
geht's jetzt alle um riesen Abstände
also unser Gleichgewicht oder eine
Chance sehr penibel auf das
bestmögliche ausgebaut also wir sind
nicht langsam wir kennen wir mit
schwerere kommen recht gut sein Recht da
im Rennen aber das heißt selbst sind
komplett gleich ja schon also vom
Schnitt schon ein bisschen 50 sind schon
ein bisschen ausklickt damit dafür dass
die schwere Ruderer drinnen sitzen
können also sie sind jetzt nicht
schmäler oder breiter Sie sagen sondern
die die wie tief das Boot liegt wie hoch
die
Bordwand ist zum Beispiel ist das
reglementiert ist das vorgegeben von
Weltverband oder kann jeder sich das
sein eigenes Verbot zusammenschweißen
und dann mit dem Starten na das ist
leider locker also es ist ganz
regelmäßig wie langer Prozent glaube ich
weiß nicht was dafür weiten gibt und wie
schwer das Prozent
kontrolliert aber das ist jetzt das Boot
selbst ohne
blöde
würde sagen dass man da mit technischen
materialarbeiten irgendwie noch ein paar
Prozent sich im Vorteil herausholen kann
so wie viele vielleicht im Windkanal
sind dass ihr ihm im Wasser Kanal zu wie
hydrodynamisch ist das Boot gibt sowas
ja das gibt Joy es wird schon viel
weiterentwickelt erst recht bei den
Rudern da ist man kommt man jedes Jahr
vielleicht Sachen drauf wie ich hier
vorne haben soll oder bei den Boden guck
mal einmal wieder auf neue Sachen drauf
also man merkt schon dass mehr Geld fürs
Rudern öfters da ist also von Jahr zu
Jahr wird es immer professioneller und
deswegen wenn er die Boote immer
schneller und härter und das wird immer
besser diese Ruder das ist ja fast schon
das richtige schnittwaffen oder das ist
eine ganz ganz scharf und ganz ganz
spitze auch ist das so dass man dann
wirklich aufpassen muss oder damit
schaffen
wir ja also nicht schwer aber man kann
schon mit dem Gott
verletzen aber das wir keiner also aber
da ist dieser
echt sehr viele Ruhe hast du daheim
liegen oder ist das vereinste Sache ich
habe gar keine Route daheim liegen aber
das ist ein neues Vereins Bruder aber
wir haben schon große Auswahl von Rudern
der Verband
gibt dann schon die Möglichkeit dass wir
testen was die besten Ruder für uns sind
also das probieren wir schon es gibt
schon mehrere Arten von Ruder von Hort
bis er bis weicher der Schwerpunkt ist
da das ist schon sehr penibel und da
haben wir die Möglichkeiten dass man sie
aussuchen aber ich selbst habe keiner
wurde ne Verein und der Verband wenn du
dann eins ausgesucht hast dass die liegt
musst du das dann anpassen beim
Skifahren wenn der Schnee härter ist
oder wenn der Schnee weicher ist dass
man dann die
materialbeschichtung anders wählt müsst
ihr bei einem Fluss so fahren und dann
so fahren ist das so ich glaube der
Schwimmer kennst das und weiches Wasser
das haben wir ja also
welches Wasser dann haben wir an oder
den den Faktor mit dem Wind Gegenwind
und mit Wind und wir haben natürlich den
Möglichkeit das Video Ruder die Längen
verstellen also je länger oder das desto
desto härter wird es natürlich im
Durchzug also dann mit so schwieriger
und also dann muss man mehr Kraft
aufwenden und ihr kürzer desto höher die
Frequenz und dann muss man immer den
perfekten Mix finden für sich selbst für
das Team Boot welche welche Länge man
nimmt ist es dann so dass man sagen kann
ein absoluter Weltklasse Ruderer wenn er
da in dieser Zusammensetzung der
Einstellungen daneben greift dass er
dann trotzdem verlieren kann gegen
andere die vielleicht rudertechnisch
nicht so stark werden also es ist
wirklich ein Faktor der entscheiden kann
laut das passiert nicht dass er Weltraum
sein soll und da geht's eigentlich nur
um Zentimeter natürlich wird kein Ruder
oder Sohn noch dem nachdem was verloren
hat das ist eine Ruder gelegen also das
wird glaube schon dass das gibt es wenn
man sie doch vergreift an dem und massiv
was einbildet und mal was falsches
auswählt aber ich glaube man das erste
Mal noch ein Rennen sucht man die Fehler
hat sich selbst und vielleicht zum
Schluss kommen die so sagen okay dass
man die Ruder aber die fahren Datum hat
er wieder Trainer mit den Ruder
Einstellungen der hat da
Meinung dafür und die haben wir recht
gutes Gefühl und recht viel Erfahrung
bei welchen Zuständen bei wichtigen
Bedingungen man welche oder Längen man
nehmen soll also wenn es nicht läuft
dann war der Trainer Schuld ich habe
verstanden
damit sehr schön wenn wir das auch so
weitergehen können
oder eben über die Frequenz das liegt
dir am meisten mir liegt es eher über
die Frequenz deswegen Leute recht viel
dass sie jetzt an der Kraft da arbeitet
weil natürlich hat jeder seine
natürliche Ruderbewegung bzw Bewegungen
und meine ist eher über die
Schnelligkeit und über die Frequenz und
die Versuche recht viel im Training
jetzt dass sie das über die Kraft also
viel mit Kraft Arbeit und das
funktioniert eigentlich seit letztes
Jahr und sehr gut also da bin ich glaube
im richtigen Weg
wie viel ist da individuell gesteuert
dass du sagst ich weiß da muss ich noch
zulegen deswegen passe ich das Training
auch so an oder ist das einfach alle
Ruderer müssen bestimmte Umfänge machen
bestimmte Frequenzen erreichen bestimmte
Watt schaffen und dann schauen wir
individuell weiter oder wird das
wirklich hinwieder angepasst dadurch
dass wir Teamsport sein und wir für
teamboot fahren ist es immer recht
schwer dass man da individuell arbeitet
im Boot also das extreme Beispiel wenn
man auch da vorne kann man nicht dass
sie auf ein oder konzentrieren muss man
schauen was das Beste fürs Team ist
natürlich wenn man in einer Fortkommen
dass das schon mehr individuell arbeiten
aber über eine auf season also bisschen
über den Winter sollte man schon sehr
individuell arbeiten und schauen dass
man seine Schwächen trainiert und das
machen wir aber natürlich gibt es einen
Grund Trainingsplan den Nationaltrainer
schreibt an dem wir uns halten sollten
bzw können müssen
dann natürlich ja so für sich selbst so
gestalten damit man seine Schwächen
arbeitet wenn man sie nicht einen Plan
hält dann kann ein Trainer nicht mehr
Schuld sein genau
aber ich glaube jeder Sportler der sich
selbst trainiert ich weiß nicht ob das
funktioniert also ich habe so nicht oft
kehrt
mich die Leute sagen dass sie sich
selber trainieren im wissen wie komplex
das ist ein wie oft auf den Blick von
außen braucht um das richtige Maß von
von allen zu finden also für mich
unvorstellbar also ich denke dass dass
man da einen Blick von außen immer
braucht was für Geschwindigkeiten
erreichst du da jetzt dem im einer im
Leichtgewicht wurde 15 km/h sowas und es
kommt der bei uns ist immer sehr schwer
zu sagen weil wir wurden dann
verschiedenen Orten und die Bedingungen
sind immer so unterschiedlich also bei
Mitmenschen und begegnet man kann es
nicht sagen also genau
Durchschnitt sagen was sie vor die
Wasser nicht gar nicht wirklich genau
im Doppel zwei genauso weniger also bei
uns wird es mit der km/h nicht so die
große Rolle sondern wir schauen hier auf
Schnitt am 500er schnell bevor und das
ist eher unsere Richtlinie wenn du dann
einen bestimmten Ort deine Distanz
schnell schaffst dann ist ja nicht nur
vergleichbar mit deinem Rennen letzten
Jahr vielleicht sogar in der gleichen
Stelle also das ist jetzt nicht so dass
sie sagen kannst mal Streckenrekord weil
eben die Verhältnisse verschieden sind
oder was oder ja schon also das macht
aber ja den riesen Unterschied zu
schwimmen der hat sehr ein gewisse
Temperatur immer und Länge also weich
ist immer alles gleich bei uns zusammen
was gleich ist ist einfach die Kilometer
also bzw
aber der Wind und die
Temperaturen sind wirklich immer
unterschiedlich also wir kennen nicht
genau sagen was was jetzt von der
Leistung her also an der Zeit kann man
jetzt sagen die Leistung war besser
sondern eher vom Gefühl und von dem
wieder Trainer die sieht deswegen ist
gerne am Ergometer die zweiten werde da
gibt es natürlich Kilometer und die Zeit
und die wirkt uns eine dann das heißt im
Endeffekt ist das Ergometer das
objektivste was ihr in der Simulation
oder Sportart habt oder also ich glaube
das ist das liegt die wirklich nie an
der und der kann der ist echt ehrlich zu
dir also der ist sehr objektiv der kann
keiner da zählt die Leistung
du wenn das sagst meinst du natürlich
ein Ruderergometer ich sitze wahnsinnig
gerne am Rad Ergometer
aber es gibt ja auch viele die sagen
dass das drinnen sitzen und das drinnen
tun überhaupt nicht ich brauche draußen
ich brauche natürlich ich brauche die
frische Luft sitzt du gerne am Ruderer
zurzeit
also ganz ehrlich ich sitze wirklich
nicht gerne Bruder aber du es einfach
für mich selbst weil ich gern also weil
ich stärker bin und meine Ziele haben
und meine motiviert bin dass sie das
machen
für radargometer einfach
weil ich das weil meine Ziele im Sommer
erreichen will und es gibt ja ein Grund
dass ihr im Sommer Sport mache ich
konnte da nie in einer Halle trainieren
oder nur indoor also nur am Ergometer
das schaffen aber natürlich ist der
Ergometer so schöner also cool in dem
Sinn wenn man sie ist so ein
Konkurrenzverhalten Gegensatz zu seinen
nationalen oder internationalen Kollegen
hat weg du kannst sie sehr gut
vergleichen einfach wie stark man wer
der stärker ist einfach es gibt für euch
auch die Indoor Meisterschaften
und Wettkämpfe hat also da wenn du dich
einmal draußen fahren möchtest dann
kannst ja drinnen auch fahren aber nur
nur zum vorstellen also wenn du seine
Bruder ergo Einheit hast dann dauert ja
nicht irgendwie 10 Minuten sondern das
sind wirklich lange Strecken die hier
der Fahrt oder wie lange dauert wenn wir
Programme haben dann eher so 80 Minuten
mit aufwärmen und wenn es um Ausdauer
geht ist besser immer über 90 Minuten
aber 90 Minuten ist ungefähr der Schnitt
was wir am Montag fahren und ja also das
zahlt sich schon aber mit ein bisschen
abwechslungsreicheren Programmen wird
ein bisschen unterschiedlichen Distanzen
und also man sagt man fort 4 mal 20
Minuten dann fahren wir halt noch mal 80
mit Pause oder 10 x 2000 Meter man
findet schon immer zu sein Ziel zu den
90 Minuten aber ja es ist schon ein
bisschen Farbe und das ist ein bisschen
Unterschied zum Rudern was draußen ist
ein bisschen in der Sonne oder am Wasser
wenn sie da bewegt sich sehr mehr wurde
Ergometer bewegt sie halt nur selber und
dann Wasser wärst du dann auch ungefähr
diesen Zeit Horizonten unterwegs also
auch dann ja anderthalb Stunden bis zwei
Stunden also das schon und der Fahrzeuge
in eine Richtung oder
man muss arbeiten mindestens dran es
kommt darauf wo man ist aber zum
Beispiel
so weiter sind die Streckennetz 2
Kilometer lang und wenn man 20 km
aber deswegen gibt man auf
Trainingslager und ist dass man mit
unterschiedliche Gewässer hat und zum
Beispiel Anne die man Ergometer sitzen
muss im Winter fahren wir zum Beispiel
noch Italien welches Wasser liegt der
meisten oder was hast du welcher Ort wo
du am liebsten gerudert besitzt in
Ordnung sein also die Idee am liebsten
trainieren aber bei München aus
Maastricht gefallen weil er recht
erfolgreich war oder in Zagreb da war
schon mit deiner erreicht das hat mir
sehr freuen und die Strecke Liebe jetzt
ja also dort wo positive Erinnerungen
habe da oder der ja gerne wie der hat
gesagt das war ja umdrehen wie lenkt man
so ein Boot wie schafft man es
das ist geradeaus zu halten oder eben
wenn man umdrehen muss
man natürlich ein Steuer also da ist ein
Steuer dabei am Fuß aber beim kleinboden
ist es immer recht gerade an jeder Seite
hat mein Bruder und das ist recht
ausgeglichen und deswegen hat man kein
Steuer und sonst sieht man auf einer
Seite einfach mehr an oder mal bremst
auf einer Seite man weiß dass ja wo dann
intensiver Sport ist auch wenn ihr das
so jetzt gegeneinander Ergometer Fahrt
und unter euch auch direkt vergleicht
ist auch eine ganzkörper das heißt der
gesamte Körper ist beansprucht
schwimmen ist auch eine ganze
Körpersprache vielleicht nicht intensiv
aber man weiß auch dass man einen
enormen Kalorien verbraucht hat ist das
etwas worauf du achtest oder gehst Du
das ja nach Gefühl von Kalorien
verbrauchen also ich bin Kalorienrechner
auf die gar nicht sondern auf manchmal
muss ich schon schauen auf das Gewicht
und wie viel wiegt dass sie mir das
Wettkampf Gewicht mit Kilo erreicht aber
sonst schaue eigentlich im Winter nicht
so genau drauf weil im Sommer so eng
darauf schauen nicht einmal loslassen
muss und locker sein muss einem Kopf
genieße das ein bisschen mehr mit
deswegen nehmen wir ein bisschen immer
zu im Winter aber das ist jetzt nicht so
tragisch damit so viel abnehmen muss
ja aber das wurde dann doch recht
anstrengend ist in dem Sinne für
Kalorien verbraucht ist glaube also das
ist ja so weil natürlich ist er
ganzkörper Sport aber man bauen umso
mehr Muskeln auf also
welche Zonen sind am meisten beansprucht
was hat sie mit Verletzungen anfällig
sage ich mal
wir treten das meiste aus den Beinen die
Beine sind sehr intensiv belastet aber
Verletzungen kriegen wir deswegen nicht
sondern das gefährlich ist eher bei uns
der Rücken dass wir oft Probleme mit dem
Rücken haben wenn der Rücken gerade ist
bzw auf Fehlstellungen im Boot haben
dann ist es schon viel oder dann
passiert dass man da am
Bandscheibenvorfall kriegt aber es ist
nicht gefährlich ist also es ist nicht
so gefährlich wie in anderen Sportarten
dass man da Verletzung kriegt also
rudern ist echt
sichere Sportart da passiert nicht viel
sogar wenn sie reinhaut etwas daneben
wirklich wäre obwohl die Marke ja sie
sogar schon mal weder
aber es ist recht sicher nicht so
Verletzung ist kein großes
Verletzungsrisiko dann wahrscheinlich
eher mit Pech gehabt
aber sonst kann man sich hier nicht weh
tun jetzt dass du vorher am Anfang
unseres Gespräches auch gesagt ein Paris
Olympische Spiele sind natürlich das
große Ziel
wie schaut ein Weg aus nach Paris was
muss alles passieren wir haben gelernt
es geht nicht im einer sondern es muss
über den Doppel zwei gehen es muss bei
mir noch sicher Riesenschritt passieren
überhaupt das Jahr ist sehr sehr wichtig
für mich ich glaube einer der
wichtigsten Sport der für mich die in
meiner ganzen Sportkarriere habe und
muss natürlich muss einfach US passen
dieses Jahr also dieses Jahr mal muss
das Team und um mich und und unser Boot
muss perfekt ausgerichtet sei auf die
Spiele und auf die Qualifikation also
für uns ist ja die Qualifikation dieses
Jahr es muss einfach alles Team passen
im Boot also mit dem Partner der mir
danach Rudern werde und das muss einfach
perfekt passen und die Form und die also
die Fitness passt und der Trainer muss
da also sie müssen einfach ohne begnade
sehr für das Ziel weil sonst
funktioniert das leider beim Ruder nicht
weil es ist bei uns so eng und so
schwierig die Qualle
da muss einfach wie es richtig sein
du bist aber natürlich da auch abhängig
wer jetzt dein Partner sein wird und im
Ruder sieht man ja einmal rutet man mit
dem einmal mit dem weil natürlich viel
ausprobiert wird wer passt wie zusammen
und was ist die optimale Besetzung des
Bootes wie stark kannst du dich da
einbringen und damit entscheiden wer
dein Partner ist oder hängt man wirklich
davon ab wie über einen sozusagen
entschieden wird man hängt schon sehr
davon über einen entschieden wird aber
das
muss man schon sehr egoistisch ich bin
im Bot da sehr egoistische kümmert mir
meinen Beruf und meine meinen Körper
also ich werde einfach immer mit jedem
als geben damit die das schnellste die
schnellste mögliche Besetzung findet und
der andere muss natürlich dasselbe
machen der will natürlich Erde ist die
schönste Boden man wird ne wenn
favorisieren oder schlechter Rudern mit
den anderen damit man mit dem Boot sitzt
nur weiß persön
fehlenden und da geht es nur darum um
die Stärke deswegen kümmern die mich um
mich selbst und lass die Verantwortung
den Trainern und ich werde natürlich
mein Meinung sagen was wo ihm wohlfühlt
und wo ich glaube das ist gut das Boot
das läuft gut und wenn im die Trainer
nehmende See zu Herzen hoffentlich aber
es da jeder Museum sich selbst kümmern
und man muss schauen einfach dass man
das die beste Besetzung findet und die
schnellste Aspekt angesprochen ist es
wichtig dass man sich privat auch gut
versteht wenn man den gleichen Putz
sitzt oder ist es vernachlässigbar wer
es kommt sehr individuell drauf an also
für mich ist es sehr wichtig dass man
sie im Boot versteht also für mich
überhaupt schon mal wenn man sie
versteht im Boden und befreundet ist und
man fährt dann Erfolge ist so umso
schöner wenn man dann noch Feiern gehen
kann gemeinsam aber es gibt es gibt da
genug oder die was anders bewiesen haben
diese nee verständungen im Boden und das
schaffen ich habe das zurzeit noch nicht
gehabt also ich habe immer recht gut mit
meinen Kollegen verstanden und
hoffentlich
wird deshalb in Zukunft so bleiben aber
es geht eigentlich wirklich nur um das
Boot selbst wie schnell das ist und um
sich selbst und das so schnell ist das
hast du auf jeden Fall bewiesen so soll
es natürlich auch bleiben noch einen
kurzen wordp mit die lieber Julian am
Schluss das wolltest du als Kind werden
er wird immer früher Polizist werden
jetzt bist du Soldat ist sehr ähnlich
auf jeden Fall gleich wichtig ohne Sport
bin ich Student
meine stärkste Eigenschaft ist ich würde
sagen meine Feinfühligkeit und meine
Emotionen das ist eine meiner stärksten
Eigenschaft dass ich recht gutes Gespür
für deshalb was gerade passiert und dass
sie das recht gut einschätzen kann oft
und dass er recht gutes Gefühl fürs
Wasser hat welche deine Eigenschaften
hindert Dich ich würde sagen sogar
vielleicht sogar Ehrgeiz hier hinten ist
oft das was mir hinter der
Unterschied zwischen Form und
müdigkeiten immer erkennen wenn ich viel
drin hier also oft mehr Ehrgeiz dass ich
zu viel will also dass sie wirklich zu
viel geben und mir nie mehr auf das
konzentriere was ich kann das ist oft
für mir Faktor im Rennen wo er dann auch
Fehler macht und das ist ja Schwäche von
mir würde sagen was würdest du sagen das
dann meine größte Stärke die dir nichts
bringt also den unnützes Talent
allgemein
mein Faulheit würde ich sagen die bringt
mir mein Leben eigentlich nichts naja
Regeneration natürlich harte voll Leute
kommen wir nicht umsonst wenn ich müde
bin dann wenn er faul also ich weiß
nicht ich wisst ja Eigenschaften die man
jetzt wirklich nichts bringen wird im
Leben ich träume von Olympia mit
Medaille und den Tanne wisst ihr auf
jeden Fall erfüllen wir wünschen dir
alles Gute herzlichen Dank dass du beim
Sportverbot was Liebe Julian danke das
war von uns vom Sportplatz bis zum
nächsten Mal ich freue mich schon bis
dann
[Applaus]